When my husband and I were in Germany,
we had the worst pumpkin cinnamon roll we've had in our lives.
When I got home, I decided to just make it myself.
Since it's pumpkin season,
there's no better time. Deseeded and roasted my pumpkin
before scooping all the flesh into my food processor
and letting that puree. Then moved on to making my cinnamon roll dough
by combining some warm milk, yeast,
pumpkin puree, egg,
and some butter,
giving that a good mix before adding all of my dry ingredients.
Let that knead for about eight to 10 minutes,
and once it all came together,
I let my dough rise for about an hour hour and a half.
In the meantime, I made my brown sugar and cinnamon mixture.
Once my dough had doubled in size,
I turned it out, rolled it out,
and spread it with some butter.
Once the butter was evenly spread,
I sprinkled my dough with my cinnamon and sugar mixture.
Make sure to rub that in before rolling it up.
Then cut my dough into even pieces
and placed it into a buttered baking dish,
making sure that they were close
but not too close so they had enough space to expand.
Let those rise for another hour,
and once they look like this,
I pop them in the oven for about 20 minutes.
I got started on my salted maple cream cheese frosting.
Combine some cream cheese,
maple syrup, butter,
vanilla, powdered sugar,
and A huge pinch of salt. Let that whisk until smooth
before spreading it all over my cinnamon rolls.
My husband likes a lot of frosting,
so I made sure to do that for cutting him one while it was still warm.
Never been a huge fan of pumpkin,
but these were divine and lucky.
I love them and gave them a 9 out of 10 which says a lot.